today's guest is a certified death man
he is uh he's that he's that sherpa that
helps you
through that last step into the final
front kia
today's guest is here to talk everything
about
everything we don't know about death
and being dead ladies and gentlemen it's
mortician
frank giles myself
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Applause]
uh we are here today with frank giles
thank you for being here man
you're quite welcome it's an honor well
it's um
it's nice to have you in here man it's
nice to have somebody that's really that
concierge kind of for the
for the dark arts you're really right
there i mean you're that last
you're kind of the bellhop for the devil
or for god really that's right
that's one way to look at it you know
you word check we're checking your
reservation or you know
we're going to get you there one one way
or the other yeah yeah uh
i got to ask you this take me through
the process of when you guys
get a body okay the first thing that
happens
is normally a phone call and that phone
call
most of the time is going to come from
either a hospice nurse
a nurse at a hospital nursing home
or either maybe even the county coroner
and they're going to call
and they're going to say you know we've
had a patient
expire or we've had a we've got a client
in need of your services
and they're going to have they're going
to say something like that
and then we're going to go through and
get some information such as
you know their name where they're
located who the next of kin is
and just some short information and then
the next thing that happens is we've got
to receive that body
entire care so it doesn't matter if it's
at a house
or a hospital or an you know nursing
home
wherever that person dies we've got to
go
you have to go to that locale we've got
to go to that location
and most of the time see i'm in a small
community in hopkinsville kentucky
we don't have pla people that
you know take bodies to the morgue and
we don't pick them up in the morning
when they call us we're rolling that
immediately
oh it's a one-stop shop over there with
you guys that's right so when you call
if you call us at two o'clock in the
morning we've got an answering service
that answers our phone at night
and so they're gonna take down all the
information and then they're gonna call
us
we're gonna wake up you know from dead
sleep
we're going to put our suits on we're
going to go to the funeral home get the
hearse
and then we'll roll into the location
now when you go to that locale do you
show up
do you go by yourself or you take a
sidekick no we've we always take two
people
because in the words of forrest gump you
know
when you go to a house call especially
you don't ever know what you're gonna
get
i mean somebody could be dead in a bed
or they could be
they could have died on the toilet like
elvis i mean you you really
don't know you got to go in there that's
right we've got to
we've got to bring that person out of
that house no matter
where they've died in the house whether
it be the attic the basement the
bathroom the bedroom
whether they be a hundred pounds whether
they be 500 pounds
you know we've got to get that person
and we've got to bring them out of the
house and to the funeral home
have you ever had to call for backup you
know you show up and they got somebody
they're real girthed out you know
somebody's real just fully just
you know just a real big dog or a big
lady most of the time
they will tell us that ahead of time you
know somebody will try to give
give us a heads up and say uh you might
need to bring some extra help or
whatever you might want to bring
somebody from the gym
yeah you know yeah you know but i've
taken as many as four or five people
out to one house you know to get a body
or you know to
a hospital you know to make sure that we
can get the body back
and how do y'all do you guys just like
everybody like on the count of three
let's lift like that kind of deal or are
the bodies hard when you get there or
are they still soft
uh it depends on how long they've been
dead sometimes they're still warm
they're still soft and warm sometimes
they've already gone into
rigor mortis and that's where they kind
of stiffen up
but you know in the funeral industry
one of the things that you will use more
than most
is a clean white sheet you know when we
go
we'll take it we'll take a white sheet
and it doesn't have to be white but any
type of sheet
will roll it under them and everything
get a sheet under them
so we can lift up on the sheet you know
we've got other devices that are
designed to do that that have handles
so if you've got a large person that you
know that are rated for you know
500 1 000 pounds and everything so that
you can
because that's the thing about a
deceased person
is they are what they what's considered
dead weight
wow and so but if you've got something
with handles that you can use
it makes lifting it a whole lot easier
okay so sometimes if it's a real big dog
or a real big gal you got to really get
that tarp under them or something real
stupid that's right
you gotta you've got to get some type of
body
mover under them so that you can lift
them up and get them to your mortuary
cot
um and it it what's the uh biggest
person you think you've ever retrieved
out there
uh probably just under 600 pounds
that's big huh that is big and so you
get the body now in a larger city there
is a
they'll go to the corner first or what
is that what is the corner
well the corner depending upon the
county and
the situation like for instance in
in our county the coroner responds if
someone isn't
under hospice care or isn't under
doctor's care
and then he responds and so
for instance like if if we walked in
and just found you dead here today then
they would call the
they would call and the police would
come and the coroner would come
and they would do a death investigation
and if they
decided that it was no foul play there's
no need for an autopsy
then they're going to call us and we're
going to come
get you so everybody doesn't get
autopsied no
no and it all depends upon your area
one thing that most people don't realize
with funeral homes and some of the laws
and things
is they are very state by state and even
in the state sometimes regional as far
as funeral customs
and like in a bigger city they're going
to be a lot more autopsies
whereas you know where i am there's very
few autopsies wow so it's just direct to
you it's direct to
farm the table really exactly because in
christian county
we don't have a medical examiner a
medical examiner is the actual person
as a pathologist that does the autopsies
okay
there's one in madisonville kentucky
that covers the whole western part of
the state of kentucky
so there's one for like a third of the
state
so you know they can't send everybody to
him otherwise he'd be overworked
yeah and so a lot of times it's just you
know
uh heart attack or you know you know
they'll go through they'll ask the
family
did he have any heart conditions what
was his medical history
and then you know they'll make their
judgment based on that
so if you had to get if you had to kill
somebody right if i'm a killer
all right you're a killer and what is
there do i want to kill in a particular
type of county that may not have
that may be more rural that would
probably be
a better better way to get away with it
in a smaller community because that way
you know they don't have all that
necessarily resources have you ever
rolled up on a body and they're like
yeah they just died naturally and you
kind of felt like they didn't but it's
not really your responsibility
no not really we've got good
professionals that they do their job and
everything else
now one time i did roll up on a suicide
and they had you know they had worked
worked it and everything else and how
they'd do it
you know they said rope or gun to me no
it was you know self-inflicted gunshot
wound to the head
you know it was from the bottom or from
the side i can't remember
but the thing about it was
they had when they'd gone through and
cleared the scene
when i went over there to start my part
i called one of the deputies back in and
i said
um do y'all want this gun for evidence
or you know because it was still right
there
oh wow they just left the gun there and
it's like okay before i touch anything
and ruin the
contaminate this scene what is what's
happening here and they're like oh we
forgot to move that
yeah i believe you did thank you captain
obvious
things get a little shoddy out there
occasionally you know i guess it was the
night shift you know
oh yeah man tonight [ __ ] that's like
when you go to like a hampton inn or
something and they got that night
manager
it's barely somebody that's even alive
sometimes you know dude they had a blind
i was in knoxville tennessee this is
probably
nine 12 years ago and they had a blind
man working as a night manager man
and he just looked trapped back there i
felt like somebody just i don't even
know if he knew where he was but
you hit that bell and he'd come out
there you know so night manager can be
anybody
um what about this so now you get the
body
okay all right so take us from there
once you get that body
um then what happens what do you do with
it
okay so when we get the body back to the
funeral home
oh yeah if the body is going to be
embalmed
then we go ahead and we start the
embalming process
immediately immediately if it's two
o'clock in the morning
we're gonna start embalming damn because
the thing about our business
is you don't know when the next person's
going to die
you might you might go a entire day
and not get anybody but then the next
day you might get four back to back
how often do people die um well for
instance we
at our current location we'll do about
funerals a year okay out of one facility
and then i've got another facility
that's going to do about 120 calls a
year
what's the most dianous time of year
when do people
tend to really just say all right i'm
gonna die i'm dying
normally normally your first quarter
january february march
why you know cold
you know stress the holidays are over
because you know i believe that
you know somebody can have the will to
live you know
and in the end you know they've got
thanksgiving they've got christmas
they're waiting you know the family's
coming in at christmas the family's
coming in at thanksgiving
but then in january they're like we
won't see them again for another year
or maybe maybe they'll come in at the
summer and
get depressed and you know hell but then
i'm out
and you know they once you get depressed
you know you kind of just
you know how it was but back when
everybody was under quarantine and
couldn't see your friends and everything
else oh yeah
everybody got depressed oh you couldn't
even tickle anybody i remember that
that's right they try to take a guy to
jail for tickling somebody
uh in pennsylvania so yes stuff just
haywire man uh so people will hold out
for the holidays hold out for that time
with the family
once the super bowl's over though people
are like oh effort i'm dead
that's right normally normally in the
funeral business
if it's your first quarter and your last
quarter or your two busiest times
okay and um so what you get that body
you know you pick that sucker up how do
you know if they're going bomb or if
they're going uh
dust because we're going to talk to the
family
most of the time we'll talk to the
family either by
the families there where the body is if
it's at the
nursing home or if it's at their home
the family's there
and we'll have a interaction with the
family and go ahead and talk to them
about some preliminary things
get permission to do the embalming and
then we'll go back
and sometimes they might say well no he
wants to be cremated or
you know we're going to do this you know
and so we want it done different but
but once we get permission we're going
back to the funeral home and we're going
to start that embalming process
now if they go cream right do you
do you how do y'all do it y'all do stove
y'all do like bar like not barbecue but
like luau style how do y'all do it
no it's more of a it's there's a crim
the crematory has this chamber
that you put the body in and that's how
the body's cremated
and is it briquettes or wood like what
is in there do you know no it's gas
oh damn because it has to be pre it's
preheated to about 1400 degrees before
the body goes in
and do you put the body in there no i've
got somebody else that does that
okay and is that a trustworthy person
usually that person to me seems
shady yeah no that's that's a very
trustworthy person
wow because i just can't i mean if i
and how long does it take to really
grill somebody down
most of the time it depends upon the the
size of the person
and how new the crematory is like a
grandparent though how much you think
oh you know you're probably you're
probably a little over an hour
damn and what about like a oh what about
that 600 pounder
now see that's different because
you think of somebody that's 600 pounds
and the fat that's on oh yeah
that becomes a controlled grease fire
so it's there are the crematories have
weight limits on them
so some crematories can only do 500
pounds
some of them can only do like 700 pounds
some of them are rated for a thousand
and so you have to um you have to make
sure that
you don't get somebody too large yeah
for that for that crematory because
otherwise you can get a prop you can
have a major problem
one of my friends who was um
who had a crematory he was cremating
somebody
and he didn't realize that they were as
obese as they were and so
he had a grease fire going you couldn't
tell it from inside
but the crematory was smoking and
they're not supposed to smoke
because the afterburner is supposed to
be burning off all that smoke
well he was in downtown in a city and
rolling black smoke he gets a call from
the funeral home
and what he just said it to cook and
left he's just like no he was sitting he
was sitting inside the building with the
crematory oh
and so he was sitting inside in there
you know he didn't notice
and he didn't he couldn't see all the
smoke outside and he gets a call from
probably a native american i guess yeah
hey man
i got some rough signals rolling up but
it was but the funeral home was actually
across the street from the crematory
and somebody from the funeral home
calling said what's going on over there
you're rolling a lot of smoke well about
the same time that they called
the fire department showed up and the
fiber department had to come
that well the fire department came
because there's all this smoke and it
it wasn't anything that needed the fire
department
but they but they just showed up wow so
needless to say he learned a lot that
day
dang so so because the body what it's
just it's just like having uh yeah my
sister sometimes her and her husband
will make um
cracklings you know they'll make
cracklings in the yard and they'll cut
up all the fat and put it in this big
open thing
and somebody's got to be right there
with like a boat or just kind of hitting
it every now and then
once they put the body in the cream
until in the end of the crematorium
into the furnace do they kind of hit it
with a thing every now and then or they
just it's one time it's kind of just
you know starting and close the door no
it's kind of start and close the door
and then and then of course they'll run
it through
you know to grind up the bones and
everything that don't burn down
so there's a grinder in there too well
no the grinders after they pull the
cremains out
okay so you put that body in you grill
them down
you know and can you do well done can
you do rare it's just one
no it's just one setting okay damn one
setting you can't you can't get a medium
rare person
yeah that's what i would go something a
little bit more you know uh
ceviche or something that's quite so
fine yeah
yeah i want to be a little grainy you
know um
so once they get that bone and
everything else burns down
you know they they take and what doesn't
burn down they run through that
kind of grinder and you know to where
they can make it real fine
okay and depending upon depending on
what crematory you use
and what kind of grinder they've got
some cremains are finer than others
really so who who's more of a fine or
cremain like what are you talking about
like a japanese guy
no no it's it's just you know because a
lot of times there's companies that own
these cr
crematories so that you don't have so
every funeral home doesn't have to own
one
there's like a third party guy that has
this crematory and you take your body
there
and you know they'll go for it for you
and so
some of those guys you know if they have
newer stuff
it might be finer than the olders you
know if they're running that push mower
yeah yeah yeah totally man yeah yeah
every now and then you get somebody who
just you know they haven't sharpened the
silverware in a while
exactly exactly like damn what do y'all
remain this thing with spoons
one thing one thing about the cremation
process that you'll find interesting
yeah if somebody has a pacemaker that
has to be removed
before cremation because that battery
will explode
no and that bat and if that battery
explodes
it can actually ruin the chamber that
they use for the cremation
wow it's like when some [ __ ] would
throw a can of wd-40 in a ditch fire
when i was growing up oh yeah
everybody's out there that can't a
hairspray yeah look at that white rain
somebody whip a can of white rain yeah
that projectile's coming at you dude
somebody's going down man
that's when you just let the lord work
man that was kind of like a rural
version of russian roulette man
everybody's out there somebody's cooking
a wiener a couple kids are just running
just jumping through the fire you notice
little evil knievels
and then some a-hole just uh just
freaking just flips a can of uh aqua net
into that bastard
that's right and you know somebody's
it's just pure luck from there on out
um okay so if those are the body you
have any questions shawn that came up we
got one from
melissa about uh hey theo this is
melissa calling from jacksonville
florida
i have a question for the mortician
um the question is have you ever had a
customer
request you to embalm them when they
were alive
gang gang gang baby beautiful young lady
asking these death questions right here
and
have you ever had anybody just want to
you know get a little hit of it
no i have not because you know i could
imagine that that would be
quite painful if you were still living
yeah yeah because you know one of the
things that we do
is we wire their mouth shut and you know
once you start
i would imagine that that would hurt and
when we do
when we make our incision to and start
injecting the fluid i imagine once
once we hit you with that fluid it's
going to burn so
say a living person even just took a
couple grand or a couple you know
20 milliliters in the arm or something i
mean would it kill somebody you think i
would i would venture to say if you were
injecting it into your artery it would
probably
would wow what's in it well
there's a lot of different things in it
there's formaldehyde
glutaraldehyde perfuming agents you know
water conditioning agents and so but the
bulk of them
are formaldehyde and glutaraldehyde
and so that's what and as a matter of
fact this is a bottle
of arterial solution really so this has
got your formaldehyde in it
and your glitter out hide in it i said
death graveyard that's right
this one's called chromatek pink made by
dodge chemical company
and who goes pink do different people go
a different color that might be for a
lady
sometimes you mix mix the colors but
most of the time you can use chromatek
pink
on a man on a woman it doesn't matter oh
i want something a little more
gray or something well you know we've
got some we've got some suntan dyes and
stuff that we can put in there
can kind of make it a little darker you
know something like that you know so
you've got some dyes that you can put
some stuff in there
and then of course the cosmetics that
you use
can also make it to where if you want
you know if you want to look like that
bronzer look you know like you've been
laying out you know you can't just came
back from florida yeah
with that one last tan huh that's right
that final tan
i love that man so you got a couple
items here you got that chromatek pink
and so that's the
that's just that big sip you put it
right into somebody right how many
bottles that you throw into somebody
well normally about two that's it uh-huh
because we'll mix this
up we'll mix this with some other fluids
that we have
you know such as a water conditioner
another fluid that's called pro flow
that's kind of like a vein
conditioner and an artery conditioner
and we'll mix all that in about two and
a half gallons
of total solution and so it's about two
and a half gallons of solution
that we put in the average body okay and
so what
that what we do is we put that and
inject that
with an embalming machine through the
artery
and at the same time it's pushing the
blood and stuff
out the vein okay so you don't drain the
body first
no it's a simultaneous process okay so
where do you put the entry and where do
you put the out tree
well different embalmers use different
locations where do you go
i normally go don't tell anybody i
normally go to the femoral down here on
the leg
okay because that way daddy getting wild
because that way if it's a
if it's a lady and she's got a low-cut
garment you know she's going to show a
little
you know show a little cleavage at her
visitation i don't blame you
you can do that you know if you still
got them exactly
if if you paid for them you know and
they're still sticking up and you want
to show it that's fine
but you know you've got so i normally go
down here to the femoral um
and i'll inject in the artery and drain
through the vein
so you'll do her in and out the same
area same locale yep
because it's because as you're injecting
it's going to go all the way through you
know through all the arteries and stuff
back to the heart and then come back out
the
veins so and so you run in two and a
half gallons you said about
normally about two and a half gallons
for the average person
and you'll flush out how much same yeah
you'll flush out the same and that won't
be all blood
you know you get about you know probably
about 75 80 percent of all the blood out
you know some of the blood's still in
the body okay but [ __ ] but yeah you'll
get out that much
so wow damn boy you rocking right there
on the cusp
that's wild you ever yeah you ever like
do you ever need a couple drinks to get
through it
no no i very i one thing about it i very
seldom drink
you know as far as you know drink
alcohol but yeah
but you know a lot of a lot of people in
the business do and it's just
all and it's all in your mindset you
know
this business isn't cut out for
everybody you know
because you think about it and
in the um one of the most popular
scriptures
that's used in the funeral business or
in the funerals
is the 23rd psalm and it talks about
walking through the valley of the shadow
of death well the shadow of death is
where i live you know that's
that's basically where i live because
somebody's dying and i'm
that's where i'm pretty much staying you
know so oh you out there voldemort man
you milling around
that's right that's right i'm just
waiting on the next one
do you uh do you ever see people around
town and you're like i'll probably get a
call on this one in a week
oh not not normally because you know
most of the time those people are in the
nursing homes but you never know
you ever want to pool with the people at
work no
no we don't as far as when somebody's
going to die no okay
that's just bad juju right there you
know then that might make you the next
person you never can tell yeah you're
right
i hate to interrupt this episode but you
know what i'm talking about right now
people struggling with nose pubes uh
people struggling with a stray hair
reaching out your nose trying to get
something
get a handful of gravy get some
and that's why you gotta take care of
yourself with the new
performance package from manscaped
trim up your manhood trim up your snout
i've i've never really enjoyed long nose
hair
and sometimes if i don't have any
feelings going on in my life i will
reach into my nose and pull out all the
hairs i can at once
just to have something and sometimes it
almost makes me cry
manscaped performance package is the
ultimate men's
hygiene bundle it includes the weed
whacker
the ear and nose hair trimmer which is
waterproof
and uses a 9 000 rpm motor powered
360 degree rotary dual blade
system look 79
of partners polled admitted that long
nose hair is a turn off
so turn it off completely
get the lawnmower 3.0 trimmer best
trimmer on the market for your balls
butt and body triple b's
the performance package is the best
value
that manscaped has to offer get 20
off and free shipping at manscaped.com
theo i'm talking to a death man today
and it can be death to the hair on your
body support
the podcast get 20 off and free shipping
at manscape.com
theo that's 20 off with free shipping at
slash manscape.com what are you waiting
for go whack your weeds
the best way to listen to anything is to
listen
through a pair of premium wireless
earbuds
you know people listen uh through
certain earbuds and natives they can't
hear everything
you'd be like oh what'd they say you got
to replay it or you don't get it you
don't get some earbuds you don't get
treble and bass you get one or the other
what what what is that
so now they have a new everyday e25
earbud
from raycon and they're the best ones
yet
six hours of playtime
six hours
bluetooth pairing more bass
you want that bass
more compact design and noise isolating
fit you want premium wireless earbuds
and you want them at a discount
and the only place to get them is raycon
there your earbuds are stylish and
discreet
or desperate no dangling wires or stems
the company was co-founded by ray j and
it's also
used by people like snoop dogg melissa
etheridge
brandy j.r smith mike tyson
they're obsessed with their raycon e25
earbuds for a limited time you can get
15 percent off your order
at buy raycon dot com slash
theo that's b u y r a y
c o n dot com slash t-h-e-o
for a special fifteen percent discount
on raycon wireless earbuds
make sure to check it out now while the
deal is running by raycon dot com
slash theo and now
back to the podcast with the death man
frank
so you got a couple items here now you
got a pint of that embalm there
and then you got this other uh little
holster here what is that
that's a cremation iron that's it's a
black onyx
cultured marble marble iron and that's
that is that a basic is that your basic
run of the mill
well that's what that's kind of a
standard you know
that some people use some people like
the marble because you can engrave on it
and it's pretty sturdy you know unless
you just throw it out the window you
know and then
but you know a lot of people use the
marble urns for cremation you know after
they've had them cremated and you know
it looks nice you can either set it on
your mantel if you're going to keep it
or you can also bury it you know put it
in a column barrier wall
there's lots of things you can do with
cremains yeah somebody
you hell it looks like you'd almost look
for dang kleenex out of that one it's
almost perfect that size
exactly uh how much cremains do you get
total hmm let's see
i would say if you were it's gonna
probably well for one thing it's if the
if the person has never had
a normal situation you're going to get
probably
somewhere around you know
180 cubic centimeters or something like
that
so how many handfuls is that you think
oh it's several it's probably going to
be about that much
oh like 40 handfuls maybe yeah
yeah it's not going to fill this up but
it's going to come pretty close
okay and is it how fine is it are we
talking
salt are we talking it's more like uh
dust sand that's down in destin are we
talking more like black beach kind of
sand you'd find out in san francisco
what kind of
it's a it's what's the vibe of that dust
that death dust
it's probably i guess a little bit
bigger than salt
okay and we is there any gristle in
there it's all the same
no sometimes there's you know you'll
catch a bigger chunk of bone that made
it through or something like that
and it's half a molar or a filling
anything like that no no you won't ever
catch anything that big normally
and normally it's pretty gray you know
it's not do you feel bad
uh having done probably you know how
many m bombs have you done
oh let's see
probably throughout i've probably been
involved in
i don't know about 4 000 or something
damn bro you going to hell bruh
you riding dark dog 4
000. so cause i've been doing it over
half my life
dang bro does one come to mind that
there was just the toughest one for some
reason
something happened no
i mean i i don't know it seemed like one
was in your head there because
because you know i think you know i
think back in you know
one of the things that's so different is
a regular embalming
you know you're pretty good you know
it's pretty much the same
you're gonna get by with a real small
incision you know something like that
and then you know that and then a little
puncture room
about the size of my pinky that's about
normal
whereas when you get somebody who's been
autopsied
you know that's when you see that big y
incision that you see on the tv
all the time and you have to you know
you have to treat
there's a lot more work to that because
you can't just
inject one site because they've already
they've
removed they've removed all the viscera
so you'll put it in it'll
start to start flowing out so you have
to you have to inject down each leg
and the arms and you have to inject the
carotids up the head
and how do you how do you if you if
there's a leak what do you do put a chip
clip or something like what do you do
just
uh well well while if there's a leak
while you're
like in the in the vessels while you're
doing it you'll put a clip on it
okay but then what you do is you have to
take like for instance
in an autopsy in a full autopsy they
remove your brain
who does the pathologist oh my god
and so when they do all that [ __ ]
when they remove your brain and all your
organs and everything else
they come back to to us and
they're in the cavity but they're in
just a biohazard bag
oh kind of like when you get that turkey
at the holidays huh yeah i kind of like
that what i'm saying is that sometimes
they take all the stuff out and put it
back in a little sack
yeah i guess i guess you can relate it
to that
and so like we have to go back and we
have to make sure
that the head doesn't leak and that we
can and then we have to sew that back up
because they don't sew it back
up because you know they'll take and
they'll cut you from behind the ear to
behind the ear
and then it's like one of these deals
where you can flip
you can flip it forward to where the
hair your hair is actually on your nose
oh wow and so and then that's how we
have to get back in there
to you know to make sure that all those
vessels
are going to be to where it doesn't leak
and it doesn't leak on the casket you
know while
we're having the visitation or the
funeral so you get the body
right and wait what is what happens to
the uh before i forget this
what about like a man's penis right do a
lot of people die holding their penis i
feel like
no you know what i'm talking about
though like i'll notice if i'm falling
asleep sometimes i wake up and i'm just
holding my penis for no reason i think
it's just a
natural thing you know it's just this is
my penis and
i'm holding it you know kind of but
does when you find a lot of bodies are
they doing it holding a certain part of
their body or they just
do some people just like do like this
like they already they're ready to die
so they know they're dying
is there any type of thing you notice
like a jet like something like a piece
out is there anything people are doing
no normally they're just you know it's
just wherever their hands fall and you
know
so a lot of times a lot of times it's
just you know if they're down beside
them
or if they're right there you know
somebody will die yeah sometimes they
you know they've got them like that
because they start to you know put them
in that
sometimes they start putting them in
that position you know but
at the nursing home or whatever do you
have you ever gone to a home
where uh they
adjusted the body after it died for some
reason like they didn't want it to be a
certain place
so they didn't they just and you were
like you didn't really ask them
questions but you're like uh yeah i know
this guy wasn't just sitting out here in
this rocking chair
you know oh no because most of the time
the people you know aren't going to do a
whole lot to the body
really yeah why is that you think
because there's a lot
there's a lot about death that people
don't understand and there's a lot of
people
that are uncomfortable around it you
know and they're just un
uncomfortable with you know the whole
death and dying process because they
aren't as
exposed to it as they used to be yeah
you know because
back in the old days where
the funeral director or the embalmer
would come to the house and he would
embalm the body at the house
no yes he had wow he had what was called
a cooling board because that was back
when they would have
like an embalmer and a funeral director
but he wouldn't that was back before
funeral homes so he didn't take them
back there you did everything at the
house or took the body to the church
but most of the time they did host meets
or something they just board them
they did the embalming right there at
the house
and so for instance um i've got
um an old glass bottle
that was found somebody found it when
they were cleaning up around an
old house and what it is is it's an old
glass fluid bottle
and when they embalmed the body they
threw the
glass bottle out the out the door and it
you know got covered up and so when they
were tearing down this house they found
it and somebody brought it to me
because you see they didn't bomb the
bodies at the house they'd come out
they'd bring what was called a cooling
board and they'd set that up and then
they'd put the body on the cooling board
and back then because they were doing it
that way
they'd they'd inject and drain right
here in the arm
so that way they could just hang the arm
off the side and then the blood would
just drip down
into into the into the ground into well
most of the time
they were doing this like in your house
so it would drip down into whatever
bucket or whatever reservoir that they
had to catch it
and when was this up until do you know
that was back until
probably you know
let's say probably back in the 40s
the cooling board what was that is that
was it a
was it ice that had ice in it or how did
it no it was just what it was called
that's just what it was called it was
just like it was
more rustic than a fold-out massage
table okay
you know that would be that would be
kind of what you'd think about it today
is
they would come up with that table and
they would
fold it out and put the body on it and
then they'd take that back with them
man when you go to pick up a body in the
middle of the night
do you knock or do you ring the bell or
people are usually standing outside
um sometimes i'll knock sometimes if i
can see them in there
i'll just walk right on in the house and
you know because i'm in
kind of a small area and a lot of times
i'll know the family
or know some family member and so we'll
just i'll just walk or
sometimes i'll knock as i'm entering
because you know they're sitting there
waiting on you
oh so frank you get the body
right what happens when you get the body
after you do the fluiding
the fluids out you got the fluid and
what do y'all do with the blood that
comes out
you really want us to answer that
question yeah it goes right down the
drain
no yes it goes right down the drain
and right into the system and you better
hope that
your water treatment guy is doing his
job because if not the
person down the river is getting it dang
so you could get that a positive hit
just on the damn
because now they treat the tap because
during this process we're always running
water
and they've done tests and they've said
that
with us running as much water as we do
that it's no difference from if you were
to cut your finger
and stick your finger under the tap
water in your kitchen
it's no difference than that blood being
diluted then when we
embalm a body then y'all drop a couple
gallons with the amount of water
because because we're constantly running
water
when we're embalming just to get the
blood off the table
and get it on down the drain and then
we're also bathing the person
while we're doing the embalming because
that massage you know when you
bathe them helps circulate the fluid now
you ever see any
you ever see you ever uh keep a little
bit of blood put it on the plants or
anything like that you ever know anybody
did anything like that
no why would you put blood on the plants
well whenever i used to live up in
uh in natchez they used to have a man
they said and he was a
um i guess he worked with blood or
something he was like a blood man
and they said he would take some of the
blood uh
and put it on his house plants at home
just to for the vitamins and minerals
you know
no i've never i've never heard of that
that's a new one on me
have you ever caught anybody in your
industry doing something vile or caught
them you know somebody's
you know it's kind of skimming off the
bottom there you know stealing blood or
you know how you know copping femurs or
something out of deceased or anything
now there have been people in the
industry especially
mainly like hospital attendants or
something like that
who have you know gotten caught you know
trying to
sell body parts or something like that
but no reputable
funeral person is trying to sell blood
or you know bones or anything that's you
know to
any black market people there's no side
hustle or anything no there's no side
hustle on that
all right there's for sure
now tell me about this so say you get
the body it's been embalmed
now what do you have to do to it okay
well the next process we would be
waiting for
would be the process of dressing
cosmetize and casketing and getting the
body ready
okay for the visitation is that your
responsibility
yes okay or that's part of my
responsibilities
now who sells the casket to him i do
that as well no way
yeah i i'm one-stop shop
hey man you like to pop a lock of death
that's right that's right now is that a
little bit of a tough vibe because i
mean you're
you know like you have to sell something
you have to then do a real business you
know
right and you're dealing with like a you
know a human life
exactly most states like for for
instance in kentucky
we have you can be either a licensed
funeral director a licensed embalmer or
you can be both
so for instance i'm dual licensed i have
both licenses okay so you got both of
them you're permitted to do it
that's right and you say you'll do it
all the time then it's natural right
now what's that base of casket man that
basic death box what's that number one
deal
so now you're talking about i'm talking
basic dog like you barely want to go to
heaven
you know you barely want to go to heaven
yeah you know
yeah like showing up to heaven on the
greyhound you know what i'm talking
about
about just a seat it ain't even a whole
ride you know
you're gonna you're talking about a
price on that yeah you're gonna be
talking about
something like 9.95 you know
so for under a thousand you can get
boxed up no that's just for the box
okay that's the box only that's not the
service right
because in 1985 the federal trade
commission came in
and they said you know you've got to
have a charge for everything that you do
so you know they said so there's no
freebies in the deaf community
right so they said you know because used
to
pre-1985 a lot of times you went into
the selection room
and that's where all the caskets are out
oh yeah and
when you would go you'd look at you'd
look at this casket and have a price on
it
and it was everything included well then
they said well somebody might not want
everything in there
so you have to itemize all your charges
and then
you you go from there and so then they
pick out all the services that they want
then they have to add their casket to it
vault if they're using a vault
and then that's your funeral total and
that vault how is the vault really
necessary man or is it better to just
get you know i want almost a gift
wrapping i want that low-key
you know well you know of some
cemeteries require
vaults okay some states require faults
it all depends
in kentucky a vault is the fault
requirement
is based on the cemetery okay but a
vault will do
two things it supports the weight of the
earth off the casket
and it also keeps water and other
elements and bugs and things from
getting to the casket
and how long does a casket last you well
it depends upon the type of casket
for instance that 9.95 brother how long
is that going to get
me oh you know it depends if you know
vault or no vault if you're not getting
it in the vault it's not going to last
very long
in eight months or something oh it's
going to depend upon well
a lot of it depends upon ground
conditions because you think
that soil yeah because if you're in if
you're in a
real wet area it's that thing's going to
be sitting in water and you know water
is not good for metal or
wood and everything else whereas it's
going to last longer if you're in a
drier area yeah
you know it's kind of like if you go
back to the ancient egyptians
some of those bodies that were just
buried in the desert where it was real
dry
they lasted almost as long as those that
were mummified
right whereas yeah you go to out you go
to like a swampy area in africa or you
go to louisiana man
that thing's just a little snack for the
for the swamp that's right
wow yeah let's hit a casket question
here what do we have here
what up the uh what up nick this is
daniel from tucson
now i know lil boosie turned down the
idea of getting into the casket making
business
but i wanted to ask your mortician what
is
the most outlandish or extravagant
casket you've seen a customer walk out
of your store with
you know did that thing have some
spinners on it
you know was it a translucent water bed
hitter
i'd like to hear about it anyways gang
gang dang bro what'd they put in there
with the most
extravagant casket you know what i'm
saying something with some cat toys
hanging from the ceiling or you got
you know you got something with a little
hot tub at one end of it what's the
wildest thing you put somebody in
well be honest well well most of the
time
the people that are buying your real
upscale
caskets are gonna buy either a bronze
casket
or a very fine hardwood such as
you know a mahogany that might be you
know where that wood was imported from
africa
and then depending upon the finish work
that goes into it because you know
whether
you know it'd be flat top and you know
par the finished parkade and everything
else
that's that's a very expensive casket
and then also you know they've got some
that are
48 ounce bronze you know and kind of
look like they've
kind of they almost look gold almost you
know and you can see
like some of the celebrities have been
buried in you know some of those like
i'm thinking of michael jackson and you
know i think um let's say
whitney houston i think was in a um
was in like a millennium that that
batesville makes
and so you know they some places will
use that as a selling point
you know because the casket companies
used to furnish a list
basically every year every couple years
of recent celebrities and what caskets
that they used
really and what happened to that list
you think
i think that you know as they've as
things have come
come on they've just quit publishing it
but you know for instance
they're used there's a company it's now
owned by batesville casket company but
it used to be called marcellus
casket company and they made the finest
hardwood caskets in the world
and oh yeah amen and so what they would
do
is they would make they would make these
caskets and one of them was called the
president
and the other is called the president
carve top and the difference between
them is the one that's the carve top
it has a lot of carvings on it but you
know
jfk and you know a lot of those
presidents were buried in those two
different caskets and so it was called
the president carve top and the
president now when ronald reagan died
he was put in a marcellus and it was
called the masterpiece
and the reason they called that the
masterpiece was
that because it had barbecue sauce in it
that casket was so big that it would not
fit in a standard burial vault
and so you know of course ronald reagan
was put in a
mausoleum that was designed to where it
would
accommodate that casket but you know
that's
that's a little bit larger casket than
your standard casket
and so you know that's that's pro you
know you see that
you know we sell some mahogany caskets
some
if we've got somebody that's going to
spend a lot of money most of the time
they buy a mahogany casket
because the look of mahogany you know it
looks really good oh yeah
and you know that's what oh god that's
what they that's what they want they
like
that warmth and the beauty of the wood
some people find metal whether it be any
type of metal to be more cold
rather than you know warm like woods
so and how pricey does that get what's
the priciest deal you guys have ever put
in the ground man
probably you know somewhere over 50.
wow you know 50k huh man
and do people on average spend more
money put burying men or bearing women
probably women because a lot of times
um you know the ma the men will care
less
but now because they will say
you know because if you think about it
most people are thinking
well you know of all the sacrifices mama
made and you know what mama did for you
and everything else and you know daddy
always said just put me in a
in a pine bat box or throw me in the
ditch or whatever but
mama i mean this is mama mama took care
of you every need you know we got to do
a little bit better for mama
yeah mama love you we gotta do something
for mama mama and jesus always loved you
theo that's it
yeah amen man
so once you get the body you got it you
got it embalmed
what do you guys what other things you
have to do to the body to make it look
presentable if you're going uh
open casket well we do their cosmetics
and of course we'll dress them in the
clothes that the family brings
and sometimes that's suit and tie and
sometimes that's
overalls and you know flannel shirt
whatever the family wants can you go
full naked or not can you go nude if you
want
uh that's probably that'd be frowned
upon you know because
you know that we wouldn't want to make
some people feel bad you know
if they weren't you know as well endowed
you know if you were full nude and you
know they'd be like
or might make them feel better about
themselves you know i just really don't
know
it'd be interesting to get a look at
that body fully nude at the end i think
it almost
would make it a little bit more like
okay they're headed they're
part of life than they are like it's
trying to make them still
look alive but you know you think about
maybe maybe more people have seen you
fully nude and more
or would expect that but most of the
time you know they want that image
as close to how they can remember that
person so unless you know america's used
to seeing you fully nude
they probably would much rather see you
with clothes on yeah
yeah that's true i think and especially
if i can eat after yeah
because you know a lot that's a big
thing is you know
the meal after the funeral because you
know a lot of times either
churches will host it or a family member
will host it at their house
and do you guys get invited to that or
no sometimes and a lot of times we get
invited
and if we're not really busy then we'll
go but you know sometimes you know right
after this funeral
we've got another one getting ready to
start so we don't have time to hit up
all those meals
and have you ever accidentally had the
had the wrong body in a cat in a closed
casket
no no because we take we have lots of
procedures to make sure you know
that we don't do that okay and then
especially since
you know we're a smaller town you know a
lot of times we'll know the person
and so it'll be like oh and yeah that's
so-and-so you know
randy that's randy so he goes in this
casket that's the oh he goes in this
casket
wow so is there any
d do you oh no oh so don't forget about
this what else do you have to do to the
body you put the cosmetics what about
like the orifices and stuff how do you
make sure that there's no leaking coming
out of the body or there's no
you know something's not going to come
out of someone's nose or eye
okay now that goes back to the embalming
process
because the majority of the time as part
of
the embalming process we do
a treatment of the organs and the
cavities
and that's where we use what's called a
trocar
okay and we use that to puncture
and suck out all the contents of the
organs
oh wow yeah so so
you have to suck out whatever is in the
stomach and everything
right wow how does that go okay
so you've got a trokar trokar is
probably you know about that long
and what is it it's it's a
metal tube and it's you got a handle and
it's got
it's got a pointed end and the way that
it works is there's slots and holes in
it
and it's hooked up to what's called a
hydro aspirator
so water's running through that creating
a suction
okay and so what you'll do is you'll
come
two inches above and to the right of the
navel
and you'll stick that in and you'll just
move it around and that's the stomach
you'll just move it around and you're
puncturing all the organs
and sucking out their contents have you
ever seen like liposuction
on the discovery channel or whatever how
they're moving it around and everything
else
it's kind of like liposuction and can
you tell what
what are people eating the most usually
most of the time you can't
tell what you know what foods it is
because of the breakdown
but what you can tell is you can tell
like for instance
you know what organ you're hitting based
on you know what's
the color of the fluid that's coming out
of it you ever been able to tell a food
no never not even like a lucky charms or
anything
not not that way now sometimes like if
we've had somebody who's
choked to death you know you've seen the
food you know still
you know when you've cleaned out their
mouth or whatever you've seen the food
still in there
you know and how far down if people
choke to death is the food pretty far
down or it's kind of close you think
well it just depends you know because a
lot of times it's
pretty well i would say it would be
pretty far down but then when they tried
to save them
some of that gets brought back up closer
to the surface but you know
they were if they were unsuccessful and
i've now got them in my possession
then you know they were unsuccessful
right then
since you've seen so and now what about
what about the mouth and the eyes and
stuff like that do you have to do
anything to keep them from like just
swinging open or the ears well part of
the one of the first things that we do
in the embalming process
is we wire the mouth shut and so
we take and we put we put what's called
a it's a needle injector or an injector
needle
and we put one up here
and one down here and then we wire their
mouth shut thank god
man and i need it a lot of these women
need it and i need it too
and then a lot of times to get that good
mouth closure or whatever you put a
little piece of cotton in there to
elevate you know like a lip or something
if it's drooping
and everything else now your eyes we
have what's called eye caps
and those look like contacts with ridges
and then we'll put those you know under
your eyelid and
use that to help keep your eyes closed
oh so you'll go eyes closed has anybody
ever tried to open the person's eyes
when they're deceased
not to my knowledge of course a lot of
times they'll come back and put a
thin little bead of glue on there and
the lips so you know that
they're also glued you know that's an
extra layer of protection gang i respect
that yeah
yeah actually you don't want somebody
you don't want somebody peeping you know
it's a funeral yeah you want somebody
looking out yeah now what he did
now what uh does anybody ever try to
come in and see somebody after they've
been dead for a little bit
after you know anybody come knocking on
the door you guys are already running
the hoses and everything and they got
somebody saying i want to see them one
more time
oh we you know sometimes like if you're
some sometimes i think what you're
talking about is like if somebody
shows up before you know
we're done embalming and they want to
see them then
yeah that we don't we don't allow them
to come into the prep room to see them
they'll have to wait until the public
visitation or you know
well even if it's a buddy or something
yeah even if it's a buddy
wow you know when because we take that
very seriously you know the private the
family's privacy
so if they've like your form we have
public when we have private family
visitation oh yeah
it's private family visitation and you
know you don't get to see them
if you're just a buddy you don't get to
see them till that public time
i don't care you know what you why you
need to see them earlier
if the family's not going to give you
permission you'll see them you know
during the public visitation
a friend of mine works in the death
trade and he's up in uh
oregon you know and he said probably
about well he worked in it about 20
years ago
he said somebody got died one time in
the town he was working in
and then while he was out at lunch they
came in and stabbed the guy a couple
more times just to make sure he was dead
goodness pretty wild huh yeah yeah he
must have
not been well liked yeah he must have
not been in my life sounds like your
friend should have locked the door
yeah yeah i think he was kind of he was
smoking weed and stuff like that
um how do you guys keep jovial when
you're working around the dead like that
you know it's just it has to be it has
to be in you
because you have to be able to separate
the fact you know that you're doing
you're doing what you can for that
family because there's no greater honor
for somebody to entrust their loved one
to you
you know because you think about you
know
this is their this is their prized
possession this is their mother their
spouse their
you know their child oh yeah and they've
entrusted that to you
there's no greater honor than that and
you do what you can
to you know treat them with integrity
you treat everybody
like it's you know your family member
and the way that you'd want to be
treated
and so you know we are very careful we
make sure you know there's
we've got you know well for one thing
you're not going to get in our facility
unless
we open the door for you you know
because the facility's locked
you know and during public visitation
we've got a
greeter on all the doors and everything
else so we
we know who's coming in and out of the
building if it's somebody you know
before before the uh nobody's sneaking
back stage
yeah because the back areas are always
locked and everything else
and so it's not easy to you know just
sneak in there and
do anything so do you feel like you
learn anything more about
life or or do you feel like
like have your thoughts and feelings
changed over the years
working in the death trade i think it's
you don't take it for granted
because you know that you can you can be
here today
and gone tomorrow you know i could get
killed in a car wreck going home
and you know am i happy have i had a
good life yes i've had a good life
we'd do good numbers on the episode if
you did though too that's
that's right not to say that out loud
but that's right hey
hey if it can help you uh you know that
that'd be all right
that'd be all right you know i went out
helping somebody else
amen man we got a question right here
what do we have here sean
we've got a question from nick
hey guys what's up this is nick from
wisconsin um
got a heavy hitter for you so over the
course of your career
how has your attitudes and emotions
towards death
changed and evolved anyways be good gang
gang
gang baby yeah how have you how if do
you find yourself getting more emotional
as you get older
with it is it hard because it just
becomes also work like
it's tough when things just become work
you know right right
you know it's the hardest part of our
job
is when we're dealing with children and
because
you know it's unnatural that a parent
should have to bury a child
and you know it's hard on that parent
whether the parents 90 years old and
their child's like 60 and dies
it's hard it's even harder when
somebody's 20 years old
and you know their seven day baby dies
you know
all that's hard you know and you you
still grieve with them
but you know the thing is at this time
you know i have to be their rock i have
to be the person
that you know you come to me i'm going
to handle it you know whatever you need
i want to handle it you put the weight
of the world on my shoulders
that's what i'm here for is there a
moment where have there been times where
you've just broken down it's just been
tough i mean there's got to be times
i mean there's times where it's been
tough you know and it's you know
and you know you'll just see it you know
and you just got to
you just got to keep on going what are
the toughest times though
you know i'll never forget um one time i
had two
you know i had um i just
completed my my apprenticeship
and you know i was fresh out of school
and i had a
i had a friend from high school
who had taken his life and i remember i
got the call
and you know that was tough you know
because
my cousin had dated him and everything
else and that was hard
then why'd he do it do you remember
no no then fast forward later
i have you know it's almost
exactly a year later another friend gets
killed in a head-on collision
and then another like
right after that another friend
dies with an enlarged heart that nobody
knew he had oh yeah
and so so you can see that all those
things play and
play an influence on you and but you
know you just have to keep on for the
family
and you know you know i'll take my time
and i'll grieve
later but you know right now i have to
be strong for that family yeah
because that's what i'm you know that's
what i'm here for
has it adjusted your relationship with a
higher power with faith has that have
have things changed for you over the
time or
you know what was that journey been like
in dealing with the uh
deceased you know i've i've always had a
strong faith
but you know when you look at the human
body
and you look at everything that goes
into it and how the
how every system of the body works and
everything else
you know that that was laid out you know
that that just
that that just didn't happen and the
fact that
you know we don't understand everything
but you know there's there's a god
that's there that does and he knows and
we
you know there's times that we think
that we would have had a better way that
we would have had a better plan
that it wouldn't have been good for this
person to die but we don't know we've
just got to wait till we
get there and maybe we'll understand it
one day at a time or
you know at the end but you know you
just got to keep on going
you just got to you know have trust and
faith and
go on does it still feel like a
human you're working with does it feel
like just a
carcass like what what is kind of that
feeling you know
because if i'm carrying a human body
that's alive you know it's a that's one
feeling but if i'm carrying just a
deceased human body i'm wondering if
that's a different feeling you know
i think that any time
that there is
a dis deceased versus a live person
there is that difference yes but the
same thing
at the same time you know
the even though they're the deceased
is not there you know as far as what
made them there
like the spirit um that body still
deserves that respect because that was
the shell
that either held that body for one day
or 99 years or 100 years you know so
it's still
it's still all there you know and still
have you seen any uh
kind of going in a different direction
here but is there anything like with
covet deaths have you seen more deaths
or anything like that
not really because you know
everything the same number of people are
basically still dying
it's just that you know if they've had
anything else but they've got coveted
right they're you know they're saying oh
it's a coven you know yeah the person
might have had covet
but they actually died from pneumonia
well instead of counting that death as
attributing it to pneumonia
they're going to say oh covet you know
or they might have had they might have
actually died from cancer
but they also had coveted so coveted
yeah they caught yeah they covered them
up
yeah people get covered no matter
everybody like yeah it's like oh they
had this but they also had coconut you
know it's like can somebody die
can somebody still just die from natural
causes or does it all have to be coveted
right you know and there's a lot of
families right now
that are very upset about that and
they'll and sometimes
we'll go to a house or whatever and
they'll be like
he didn't die of covid she didn't have
the cove and make sure that they don't
put covet on the death certificate
really and it's like well you know the
doctor the doctor's the one that fills
that portion of the death certificate
out
but we'll make sure to tell them that
they didn't have covet
because there's a lot of people who are
so
tired of hearing about it that they're
you know that they want to make sure
that their loved one isn't a statistic
for something that they don't
you know that they don't necessarily
it's not that they don't believe in it
but they don't want them to just be a
covent statistic yeah you know a talking
point for somebody that they don't like
now what about this what's a wild thing
somebody wants to have in there when
they die somebody throw in a little can
of ruffles or somebody put a little
couple starbursts in there or something
okay you know it's it's not uncommon a
big thing a lot of people will take
cigarettes with them
you know because you take somebody who's
smoking a boy
you know they'll put those they'll put
that you know cigarettes in that shirt
pocket you're gonna want that smoke dude
if you did
if i'm dead bro light me up a damn 100
baby you know what i'm saying i'm
burning a [ __ ] winston
if i'm dead man i ain't milling around
you know i've had you know you know a
lot of people put pictures of themselves
you know and what about a joint somebody
sneak a joint in there sometimes
um i'm not gonna say that that's never
happened because you know
when we're when we're standing back up
there and the family goes up for their
final viewing there's no telling
what they can stick in there you know
i've had i've had some very interesting
stuff you know i had somebody
request to be buried with their shotgun
amen you know so they took their shotgun
with them
you know what about can they now if
somebody requested me bear with an eight
ball
you know and i'm not talking bowling i'm
talking about cocaine baby
can you make can you make do you have to
do that
well the thing about it is since that
would be an illegal drug
you know we wouldn't be required to do
that but you know if somebody
if somebody were to bring that in and
you know stick it up under the foot of
the casket
you know i'm not i don't keep a drug
sniffing dog at the funeral home
so it might just go on through you know
they might just go with them that might
go with them yeah so
yeah that's one thing there's no tsa
when you're flying up to heaven
that's right that's right you're not
gonna be you're not gonna be searched
you know so now uh what's the wildest
thing somebody's put in there somebody
ever put something that's a little too
big in there
you know somebody tried to put a little
chainsaw or a leaf blower or something
if somebody died doing a uh
you know during a dangerous you know
leaf blowing or something you know no i
don't think they've
had any power tools or anything like
that you know
sometimes you have like stuffed
animals or whatever you know even for
like an older person they'll bring like
stuff to animals they'll bring blankets
sometimes
and you know we've had um you know like
fishing rods you know stuff like that
that have gone with them but you know as
far as
you know i've never put i don't think
any power tools in there
but i'd go with a damn sander or
something you know
so what are you going to use that sander
for who knows but
but i'll tell you this if you show up
and you the only dude with a sander
you're going to be
you're going to be steady working that's
right but we're not supposed to work in
the afterlife but i'm sure there's a
couple of opportunities to make a lot
you always
want to decide i want that side hustle
now do you take those items out or those
those items go on
the family gets it's the family's choice
if the family
wants something in there for visitation
and then they want that back we'll take
it out but if they wanted to go with
them
it goes with them now you close the
casket during the
if it's an open casket you guys close it
during the procession
or funeral deal it depends on when the
family wants that closed
okay they want it closed at the
beginning of the service
some families like for everybody to file
by at the end
one final viewing and then after that
after the family goes up for their final
viewing
then we close the casket so a lot of
times that's up to the family
and so um and now is it hard for you
personally do you have trouble is it
tough to meet women or something like
that if you working in the death trade
you know
i could imagine it might be a little bit
of a
or is it kind of a talking point you
know well you know it's one of those
things that
you know that they that they might be
interested in
they might have a few questions but you
know it's not
i would not say that it's a chick magnet
you know i you know that they're
flocking towards the undertaker because
you know
the thing about it is
when that call comes in i'm going on
that call
so you know if i'm on call you know i'm
going to be leaving at the middle of the
night and everything else
and a lot of people you know they get
you know they don't like that
yeah they don't like that you that
you're going to be gone for that
they don't like that you've got to work
on the weekends
at night holidays that you miss
birthdays and everything else
you know because it's a big commitment
you know when you're when you're working
in the death care business because it's
24 7.
i mean because there's i probably since
since i've been involved in the funeral
business i've probably spent as many few
holidays at the funeral home as i have
at my house
wow and so it's 50 50 split huh that's
right
you just don't ever know and you know
that's the last thing that you know
a girl wants to be on the way to a nice
dinner then oh i've got to go to the
funeral home
and they ever bring a date over there
witching to say this
no no no because then
now keep i keep them keep pretty
separate yeah
is it tough dating in a small town is it
tough dating in a small town
you know it it depends especially
especially when you're in our business
because you get to know
the families oh yeah and you know
because you're spending three or four
days sometimes
with the family in the um in that and
you really get to know them
and sometimes you become like family to
them
and sometimes you're like stay away from
them you know sometimes you learn a
little too much yeah
you learn a little too much and so that
that makes you want to shy away from you
know some of them anyway
so do families uh can somebody get
buried with their money if they want to
if they want to bring it in they can get
buried with it have you ever had
somebody that that was their request and
they put it in there
not all their money you know i've i've
had people you know want to get married
you know
with you know granddaddy always wanted
him kept a
you know a two dollar bill or you know
he always had
change in his pockets you know didn't
want to go anywhere without a little
money
you know i've had that but i've never
had anybody say we're gonna put a
million dollars in this casket
yeah because you know then you
then you get to the age-old question
if you put a million dollars in there
let's say you put a million dollars in
there in cash
and then if somebody would take the cash
and write you a check for it you've
still got a million dollars
so so nobody normally puts cash in there
they just maybe we'll put a check
yeah so i guess if you want to i guess
if you wanted to go with a million
dollars we could write you a check for a
million dollars because
you wouldn't be able to cash it yeah
yeah i'd rather send the check
yeah just in case later you decide dang
i wish i had that cash
yeah yeah yeah but nobody ever puts
million dollars or anything in there
you know so um have you noticed over
time that people very
used to bury nice things with people and
now they just kind of bury whatever with
them
you think has it been any been able to
notice anything like that
you know most of the time people if it's
something of real value they keep it and
they pass it down in the family or
whatever
you know you especially jewelry and
stuff like that
and of course now with you know there's
so much stuff that
you know people are using like costume
jewelry and stuff like that
that people are wearing rather than
buying you know
real expensive jewelry that they're
doing that they're doing that
and especially for um especially for
your older people
because as they as they get sometimes
dementia and stuff like that
the family's already taking their good
jewelry away from them
so they don't lose it because you know
they don't want them to keep the good
jewelry
in the nursing home or stuff like that
and
you know because they'll you know
they'll lose it or somebody will steal
it or whatever
now i have had families bring in really
nice jewelry for the visitation in the
funeral
and then they want that back and so have
you ever stolen anything from anybody
no sir no sir that that'd be bad for
business
yeah it'd be bad for business man i
didn't think you had but i just had to
ask you
um we got any other questions that came
in that are unique yeah we uh ross has
another question about caskets i'm out
here in new york just a quick question
for the mortician
open casket or closed casket me
personally that open casket
if it was me i'd feel a little
disrespected i'm not gonna lie you know
but now that's it gang dang bro
how you go man how do you suggest you
know you got the you know you've been
around the way you're really the wrecks
ryan of death right here so
what do you say it depends upon how they
look
i think that the family should have it
should be able to have an open casket
if the person resembles himself but you
know if they've been in
very bad trauma if they've been you know
in a situation
where you know they've got a cliff fall
or something yeah
car wrecks you know something like that
but you know if they look like
themselves i think the
fire face fire yeah face fire you know
um bush hog you know oh yeah oh
i used to drive a bush hog man
accidentally killed a deer man that was
just sleeping one time
yeah i felt horrible about that i still
feel bad about it but
uh so you're saying if they look decent
enough you'd go open casket
you gonna go oc you think i think so
dang
you heard it that's right that's that's
my plan i want everybody to see me one
more time
yeah now some people the it start their
faces get fat
i noticed that the last funeral i went
to people's face get
fat when they lay them down like that
well some of it could be
that they that they swelled them during
the embalming process
or if they were in the hospital for a
for a long time that could be part of it
or sometimes if you've got somebody who
kind of has
jowls and you know well when they lay
back
those fall back and so it doesn't make
them look like themselves because that
should be
that should be up here whereas it's
laying back
how hard is that body when it's laying
in the casket is it pretty hard
it depends upon how
how hard you set it up and what i mean
by that is
this embalming fluid the more you put in
the more it's going to harden somebody
up
so you can set them up like really
really hard
but the problem with that is it's going
to
dehydrate them a lot so basically you
can do that but they're going to turn
more to leather and they're not going to
feel like a human body
and they're going to dehydrate and so
it's going to require
a lot more cosmetics and stuff and make
them look unnatural damn
is there any perfect way to do it man i
can't believe there's only embalming
and creaming or cremation
but i think i'd love to be damn wrapped
in bacon or something you know i'd love
to be this
you know i'd love to be uh what's the
one where they cut you open and put
cheese in you
you know um cordon bleu
or i'd go stuffed crust son stuff crust
would be great
and so now they do have sometimes we do
what's
what's called like a green burial
and that's where somebody is still
buried but they're not embalmed
and so they don't want to be embalmed
and they just want to
be more natural and sometimes they'll be
you know just like in a
wood casket and buried in a cemetery
without a vault and everything else
because they want to go back to the
earth as quickly as possible and is that
growing in popularity
in some areas it is but you know the
jews don't embalm
an orthodox jew does not embalm wow
that's one of the things you learn when
you're in mortuary school
is different religions and kind of how
their preference is
and i'm not for sure if you know this
but
i went to mortuary school here in
nashville
there's the mortuary college in
nashville it's called john a gupton
college
and it's over on church street and one
of the things that they do
is your last semester of mortuary school
they assign you to work one day a week
at a funeral home
as part of your schooling so they've got
certain funeral homes that they'll
assign you at
and i worked at one here in nashville
and it was
and it was the jewish funeral home wow
and so
so there's no embalming there there's
not for the jews
and they're real they're real strict
about it
and so basically why it's just kind of
in their doctrine
yes and they would have they have
the guild that comes and washes the body
and wraps the body and prepares the body
it's a sect from the church and then we
would put the
body in what's called an aaron and what
that is is that's a jewish casket
that's entirely made of wood wow and
then we would take it to the cemetery
and bury it how quickly pretty quick
pretty quick normally
normally if they died normally if they
died
today it would be by sundown the next
day
how fast can you get me in the ground if
i die you guys do any like eight hour
packages or anything like that hey we
can get you in the ground pretty quick
depending upon the cemetery amen
so you know used to
and how deep can you get me can i go 12
feet or it's only six
no you can go you can go deeper because
cost more
now as long as the ground is good you
know because sometimes you
you've gotten cemeteries and you get
down so far and it's solid rock
you know you hit that bedrock and
everything else but
like for instance there's cemeteries
such as
a lot of veteran cemeteries they do
what's called double depth
and so like if you've got a husband and
wife
they'll they'll put the first one that
dies they'll put them down
you know probably 10 to 12 feet and then
and then when the second one dies
they'll dig down
part of the way and then they'll put
them there and so they're
they're double depth now different
states have different requirements
and most people you know have that
ingrained in their head
that oh i'm six feet deep well in the
state of kentucky
the law says that if you're if you're in
a burial vault
there only has to be 18 inches of dirt
on top of you
now most of the time there is more than
that but that's what the
but that's what that's the minimum legal
requirement so you could go shallow here
over in kentucky you go 18 inches damn
anybody do it still sometimes
i mean most of the times not but but you
know
and what it is it's used to when when
graves were dug by hand they used to be
sometimes
more shallow than they are now when
they're dug by
by machine you know i tell you when i
was growing up they had a man in our
neighborhood who died
and uh and they buried him in the
backyard
they buried him in their backyard and
they invited me and this one kid over
there to the
to the service and we didn't know what a
service was we never seen it or anything
you know
and they said you want to come to a
service and we thought maybe it was like
tennis or something you know
but um we got back there and next you
know we're all sitting in these folding
chairs and they're burying us
this dude this old dude mr polito and
they just put him in the ground man
and they said anybody want to say
anything and
my friend summer all due this young
fella he said grace like you would say
over dinner
you know he didn't know what to say you
know so his little wild ass said
uh god is great god is good god we thank
you for this food i just remember
standing there
just being like what in the hell's going
on you know
um do some families still just bury
their own
um they're they have to be buried
you can't be just buried on your
property unless there's a cemetery there
now how do you get it legally
symmetrized um
well if it's just a family cemetery
it's the biggest difference is whether
or not you're going to be re
selling plots if you sell plots to other
individuals
that's a whole lot more red tape than if
it's just going to be a family cemetery
but you have to have it you have to have
so much
area set aside for the cemetery it has
to be reflected in the deed
you have to have permanent egress to it
and so there's a little bit of work that
has to be done
and it has to be fenced and so there's
some stuff that has to be done legally
to make those requirements
but if you meet those requirements
you're good and do you guys
do you get involved at all if it's a
family cemetery yes
we will still be you know doing the
embalming and take them out there
and make sure everything's done legally
so you can't just go straight from the
kitchen table somebody chokes to death
and just
hold them up in the backyard there's
nobody to do that route yeah you can't
do that
because there's got to be a couple steps
in between there
you guys ever run a coupon deal or
anything like in the summer or something
like that you know no
no we don't ever run that blue but light
special or buy one get one free or
whatever
nothing like that no it would just taint
the industry huh
that's right i i
hate my phone bill i hate it it's
expensive
i have to give them money but i get to
keep using my phone
well now premium
wireless just got cheaper
with mint mobile they're introducing
their unlimited data plan for just
30 bucks a month let that sink in
just 30 bucks a month how much is your
soon to be
x wireless provider charging you for
people that hate their phone bill and
are ready to cut
ties with big wireless mint mobile
offers their premium unlimited plan for
just 30 bucks a month
by going online only and eliminating the
traditional
costs of retail mint mobile passes
significant savings on
to you use your own phone with any mint
mobile plan
keep your same number along with your
existing contacts
and if you're not 100 satisfied mint
mobile has you covered
with their seven day money back
guarantee that's right
to get your new unlimited plan for just
30 bucks a month and get the plan
shipped to yo dough for free
go to mint mobile.com theo that's
m-i-n-t
m-o-b-i-l-e dot com slash t-h-e-o
cut your unlimited wireless bill to 30
bucks a month at
slash mintmobile.com oh
if you're listening to this past weekend
then you probably have some mental
health issues
like me sometimes it's hard to find help
sometimes you might live in a barn you
might live in a forest
but betterhelp will assess your needs
and match you with your own licensed
professional therapist
you can start communicating in under 24
hours
it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it is professional counseling
done
securely online
you know you could pull over to the side
of the road get on face time with your
counselor boom
right there better help you can
communicate by text you can communicate
by phones
you can communicate by different ways
you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses you can schedule weekly video
or phone sessions
better help is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches
so they make it easy and free to change
counselors if needed
if you need help give it a try
better help want you to start living a
happier life today
visit betterhelp.com theo
that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
and join the over half a million people
taking charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional special
offer for this past weekend listeners
get 10 off your first
month at betterhelp.com
theo if you need help
look into it and now back to the episode
any more questions that came in brother
this is from
cole hey theo
um mortician
um just got back from a run got that
zen pack in up top okay um
so mr or mrs mortician i was wondering
if you've ever uncovered anything
inside or like on someone's body
maybe that hadn't been picked up yet and
uh it's like something kind of like
silence of the lambs but
uh maybe not as morbid um i guess
um and how did you get into more
mortician ray
thank you i don't know what he means by
that first part
have you ever uncovered something on
somebody yeah yeah you ever found yeah i
guess you ever gotten somebody back to
them to the
uh morgue is it called a morgue well
where we take away to be back to the
preparation room
okay you ever get somebody back there
and you find something in their pocket
you know you find a couple pills or you
find a little you know
something like that a snack a
butterscotch anything like that
yeah no i've never really take you know
get gotten anything
body back there and then just over it oh
well here's a handful of pills that was
missed or you know something like that
and because normally normally they've
had
they the coroner's office or whoever has
checked the body has been pretty
thorough
to make sure that everything is you know
that they
kind of do an inventory and that
nothing's missed
okay because they you know they kind of
have to do those steps before they let
us
take responsibility for the body now
what what about with
is there one body type ethnicity that
keeps a little bit better than others
um i would i wouldn't say so you know
they
you know it's all it's all the same as
far as
the body you know and everything else
now sometimes
um dehydration and stuff
if on a pale person when they start
dehydrating
and they start getting a little bit
darker it shows up
worse on a pale person yeah than it does
somebody who's
you know darker skinned and what's the
final lacquer you can put on somebody
how much is it to get a dang just a nice
you know
i'm talking two coats of just a matte
finish you know something uh
you know not sherwin williams but
something nice you know duloth or
whatever it's called well you know we've
got different cosmetics and believe it
or
you know most of the time you can
you know you'll just put a light very
light coat but then we have
sometimes you have to mask somebody and
when i say mask somebody that's when
you're putting a lot of cosmetics on
them
because something went wrong what do you
mean something went wrong like they felt
like they died by some ants or something
you know if they died and they you know
and they
for instance let's say somebody died and
they were face down and
nobody found them for a while but what
happens
is in the body the blood will
settle to the lowest point you know
the blood starts settling so if so if
you're
if you die face first downhill then
then it's gonna then a lot of the blood
is gonna run to the face
well what happens as as that blood
runs to the face if it starts
in these capillaries on your face if
those start getting so much blood in
there
that they have that they can't handle
the pressure they'll pop
and once that happens that blood runs up
runs out into this tissue and that's
that creates a condition that we call
postmortem stain
and if it's post-mortem stain you can't
really get that out
damn bro and all you can do is cover it
that postmortem stain baby i don't want
that
no so if i die what's the best way for
me to die then
um the best way for you to die would
probably be
in your sleep okay but with somebody
checking on you so they'll
be so that they don't let you just lay
there for hours after you die
so after i'm dead what should someone
just roll me over like every 30 minutes
or something like what's the best way no
they should call me okay after you die
that's what you should do you call it
you call frank giles that's it you call
frank jobs
that's right that canary baby he'll get
over there and help you to
uh help you to the afterlife but what's
the best way for somebody to take care
of the body do they
should you rotate it every 30 minutes or
what should you do no just leave it
there you know
front down or back down oh back down you
know head
head slightly elevated okay and then so
put a book under the head maybe or a
pillow
okay a pillow is always nice yeah
another
thing that i want to tell you about that
is um
are you familiar with jaundice oh yeah
my sister had john that's growing up
okay well jaundice
will react with formaldehyde so we've
got a spec
there's a special fluid that you use for
a jaundice body
and if if you don't
use the correct fluid and you like if
if you had jaundice really bad and i
just poured this chromatek pink to you
well the formaldehyde in it will react
with the bilirubin in the jaundice
and it will cause the body
to turn green just smurf out almost like
shrek
you being shreked out like green and
have you ever has that ever accidentally
happened
well i've had it happen where
where like somebody died in another
state and they sent them in to me
and i got this lady one time and by the
time she got to me she was green
and so then what we had to do was we had
to
all we could do is cosmetize over it oh
yeah because you can't go back in and
reverse that
and so so they might be green underneath
huh uh-huh
wow could i take a sip of that you think
it would would it hurt me
oh yeah it hurt you yeah it's you know
they've got
they've got all kinds of warning labels
on there poison you know
do not drink and you know and it's also
a known carcinogen
so yeah so they you know they tell you
that you know
it's going to cause cancer if you get if
you're exposed to it too much and
i still work with it every day wow you
know that's the risk i take
yeah dang if you're helping people with
cancer you might get it
damn but you know that's that's why i do
what i do you know
because i'm helping the family yeah now
can you eat near the bodies or not
it's frowned upon you know
people you know people don't you know
it's now you're you're
talking about when the preparation's
going on yeah that's frowned upon
now if you're saying if somebody's let's
say you're having visitation
and the widow's standing up there you
know in the receiving line and she's
eating a cracker
or a sandwich or whatever you know
that's her call yeah you know
but what about you while you're fixing
the bodies up you know
and you guys are there finishing off a
reuben or something you ever had yeah no
that's frowned upon you know they
they oh she doesn't like for you to eat
or drink in the prep room
damn because sometimes i'd want to have
a beer or something by a body
you know so that's yeah that'd be
frowned upon have you uh had to bury any
of your own family
uh yes um when i was working there um
one of my grandmothers died and so we we
handled that
i've had some great ants and stuff like
that that have gone through the funeral
home
since i've had it but both of my parents
are still living and all my other
grandparents were already dead before i
got into the funeral business
but i've had lots of cousins and people
that i've known who've come through the
funeral home
do people look at you weird because you
work in the death trade
uh most of them have gotten used to it
now when i was in high school
um the principal he and i got along
pretty good
and he used to always pick on me about
it he'd be like
giles i don't know what you're doing or
sometimes he'd just look at me and be
like you're sick
you're sick and twisted yeah is he dead
or not no he's still living
he'll die he i saw him at the funeral
home
probably about a month ago he said well
i see you're still here
yeah got your name on the side say it'll
be you soon
um now what about our body like now what
about like our colon and feces and stuff
like that what happens to that part of
us
that's that's one of the things that we
suck out with that trocar
okay you know we'll suck we'll suck that
crap out of you dang and how long does
it take
just depends kind of yeah it depends
upon you know what all is
in the body and everything else and you
know because some conditions
put more fluid on the body and
everything like if there's somebody
that's very edematous and they've got a
lot of
extra fluid we put extra fluids in them
to
kind of get that fluid out and to try to
draw that fluid off the body
man and uh and so all that just goes
down the drain and then what do you put
in the colon what do y'all fill it up
with
we have a different chemical that is
very similar to this
it looks the same just different color
but it's designed to go back in there
and to treat those cavities
wow what color is it it is kind of a
greenish blue
okay and do you sew up the butt the
sphincter do y'all sew that closed no no
really yeah
y'all just leave it open well i mean
normally it's
you leave it natural dang and that thing
stays natural
most of the time yes wow so now what if
it gets a little unnatural you got a
little clip or something a barrette or
something you put on there
uh it's um more of what would be
more like a plug a spackle or something
so
or you can always caulk it what do you
do be honest no it's
it's more like a cork more like a plug
wow
now of course if you go old school
old school would be you would stuff it
full of cotton
because but cotton in somebody's booty
like a build-a-bear
yeah i guess if you want to call it that
but they're used to sometimes people
used to refer to
morticians as cotton stuffers because we
used a lot of cotton you know
to build up different things and you
know and so they used to have to put a
lot of cotton in there
especially when the fluids and the
procedures weren't you know
as great that they used to put cotton
you know in
basically every orifice that you could
leak from they'd stuff it full of cotton
oh my thick ass i'd take up yeah i'd
take half a rabbit probably man
i'd need a decent amount uh any other
good questions we got here let's get to
one more and then we'll uh
we'll just thank you for for coming
right wow
what's up you death daddies got a
question out there first of all gang
gang baby i was wondering my granny she
used to uh she used to be beautician but
she used to
you know night night time as that uh
mortician okay moonlighting with the
decision
she would go in there and uh she would
do the makeup for the deads
you know them deceased and i was just
wondering
because she had some wild stories have
you
working in there at night time by
yourself
deep in those depths of hell
have you ever experienced anything a
little nutty
a little odd you know
anyway gang gang death death baby
death dog now yeah because a lot of
people probably see you as like a hell
boy almost in a way
and so have you ever seen like any ever
had any spiritual experiences when
you're in there like have you ever does
it get a little haunty i would imagine
it gets kind of haunty huh
no it you know it's one of those things
that
you know you're just there and it's not
necessarily
like i don't ever feel like you know um
there's ghosts or anything there you
know
and i've never had any you know quite
crazy or wild experiences
with any of the bodies or anything like
that i've never
you know felt like there was somebody
else there or anything like that you
know some
sometimes people will ask me that
question similar to that but yeah
no i've never experienced anything like
he's talking about
wow so in the end
in the end of it all you're saying you
go open casket that's the way to go huh
that's the way that i want to go but you
know that's my choice
and you know at the end it's
it's a personal choice and what's what's
right for me might not be right for you
you know you might want to be burned
that's fine
that's your that's your choice my choice
is i want to be opencast
because i want to have you know i want
to have one more one more good suit on
you know so
everybody can see it and everything else
yeah and so
but that's that's the way that i want to
go i want to be dan cremer laid i feel
like or honey mustard i want something
i'm ready for that next level is there
something new
on the horizon of burial that's starting
to kind of peak its head about anything
you're hearing
well there in some states they have this
it's similar it's kind of like
what they call a flameless cremation
but it's very similar to the air dryer
kind of
no it's more like how you see those old
movies where the
mob would put you in a 55-gallon drum
full of chemicals
and then you disintegrate it's more like
that but that's not
that's not recognized as in some states
that flameless cremation yeah it's not
recognized in kentucky yet okay but i
know a guy who's got that
business in missouri and he does it for
other funeral homes or whatever
because most of them haven't made that
investment because it hadn't caught on
yet
you know some people are thinking that
you know
freezing people is going to be the next
thing right but you know you just
you just don't ever know until that next
thing gets here
how has the business been is it still a
good business to be in it's still a good
business to be in
now the business has changed a lot from
what it used to be
what most people don't realize is that
there's funeral homes that are what what
are considered to be locally owned and
operated
like i've got a business partner and he
and i own the funeral homes
where and then there's also corporate
funeral homes
and those are funeral homes that are
owned by your major corporations
and i mean they're traded on nasdaq no
way i mean you know
the stock exchange yeah so you know
there's companies
that own funeral homes all across the
country and you know
they just buy and sell at funeral homes
and they
and that's what they do and is that a
little bit does that get a little less
personal care you feel like when you get
involved with those big dogs i feel like
some of those big
big ones there they're not necessarily
in it for the family they're in it for
the money
and they're just trying to cut corners
so they can make more profit
you know i i've born and raised
where i work and i see those people
every day and i work with
those are my friends and i'm not going
to take advantage of them
and i'm going to treat them with that
most respect that they deserve
and i'm going to do everything i can to
make sure that they get a proper burial
or cremation if that's what they choose
and i want it to be the best that it can
for them
whereas you've got somebody who doesn't
know these folks
taking care of them they might not try
as hard that's not as important to them
you know because the person that lives
down the road for me
all my life they're important to me
they're not important to whoever owns
you know some stockholder
in california or texas you know deaths
are us or some place
exactly exactly right and so
you know but that's that's the thing you
know you always know who you're dealing
business with
yeah and you know there is something
nice about that known when you die who's
going to handle you
exactly because you you know you
sometimes i have families that
you know they'll call they'll call me on
the on my cell phone they won't even
call the funeral home number
they'll say you know mom died we need
you to come
and so here i come yeah it is something
nice about knowing the person that's
coming in
exactly somebody doesn't have to come in
with a name tag on or
you know uh you know they don't even
yeah somebody don't know you
right you know somebody that comes up to
the door i don't want somebody pulling
up and honking
you know like it's a you know like i'ma
carry him out there
like the other day i went to went to a
you know a house and i did not know the
i did not know the deceased
but i was standing there talking to the
deceased wife and then
the sun came around the corner because
he'd been
back in one of the bedrooms getting
something for his mother and then he
came out of the
back bedroom and i knew him you know i
went to high school with him
so you know so that made her feel better
knowing that oh he knows my son he for
sure gonna take
better care of my husband and everything
else wow and you know that's what we try
to do
and is there something killing people
that you've noticed more over time like
uh you know you always hear about drug
deaths and this and that are there
things that are growing that you're
noticing here at the
at the end of the line well you know it
wha
before you know before covet you know
they were talking about you know the
the drugs and the narcotics yeah
oxycontin and all that kind of thing
are you noticing it we were not having
that big of an issue
there in hopkinsville where they were in
some of the other cities where
you know and i think it just you know
sometimes it takes a little bit longer
to work its way through and so drug
overdoses were
a big thing especially in some of the
bigger cities
it seems to have tapered off in the
moment
or you're just not hearing about it but
you know that does happen
um and sometimes you know
if there's one drug overdose you're
going to get some more
you know especially if you're a batch if
that batch comes through yeah if a bad
batch comes through you know you can see
several oh yeah and you know and that's
just that's the thing about
drugs that people get so dependent upon
them that you know
you can have a bad batch come through
and lose
five or six people oh [ __ ] we had a some
lsd come through one time and
people couldn't even tie their shoes for
a damn month you know yeah sometimes you
just don't know what these drugs are
gonna do to you
you don't and and some of these cancer
drugs and
these drugs that these people that
they're putting people on to
save you know to try to prolong their
life
are actually having reactions with like
the formaldehyde and stuff like that and
so
you know you're getting sometimes a
graying
a graying effect or you're getting
different effects on the body based on
the chemicals that they're putting in
them
to try to save them and so you don't
know that until you really put it in huh
exactly yeah and so that's one of the
things
that you're trying to counteract as to
what you know what drugs that they've
been on and everything else
somebody comes out that damn turkish
gold tent or something that's why
you've got some of these accessory
chemicals that are supposed to help
balance out the ph
and everything else that's in these
fluids it's like treating the pool
almost huh
exactly exactly because you know part of
that
part of that that goes in there is water
so you got to make sure that the water
is good and everything else
you ever feel somebody a little too much
you're like oh damn we put a little too
much in them
uh not so not really because it's
because as you're putting that in it's
still pushing it out so you know it's
you you're getting it right back out so
i see it once so once it stops coming
out that's when you know to stop filling
well no you you know by the what's
coming out
you know because you can tell when you
when you're draining
the blood you know okay this is blood
now this is
right now i'm getting a lot of fluid
back and so you've
oh yeah okay you've run its course yeah
so you can kind of tell that
man i think that might be about
it sean you know anything else anything
we missed
literally huh who has the best funeral
music
is it really like that i would feel like
at black funerals you'd have better
music do you just have it
well it just appears i've been to black
churches growing up i go to black
churches man
and dude you feel like you're sitting on
the lord's lap you know at a black
church
right right and you know that's one of
the things about it
is here in the south you know
just like church you know and this is
not this is not a racial thing
but just like how church is pretty well
segregated
here in the south so are funeral homes
most of the time
you know for instance um the cam the
city that i'm
in we have um primarily white funeral
homes
and primarily black funeral homes that
doesn't mean that i won't bury a black
person
or they won't bury a white person but
people really stick to their uh
they'll stick to their culture their
culture their upbringing
and it's it's who they know right you
know they went they've known him all
their life and
you know they've the others have known
me all their life and it's just
you know just like how they choose to go
to church
you know the the church is product
predominantly white or black
yeah you know that's kind of how they
stick to with the funerals because
that's
oh your funerals and your funerals and
your church services a lot of them go
hand in hand
they cross over you know one of the
things that people don't think about
with our job is all the coordination
that goes involved
that's involved you know throughout the
lines when somebody dies
or whatever one service that um
that i'll talk to you about for a minute
um the gentleman
was kia and that's military terminology
for killed in action amen but
he was killed in action in world war
ii so he dies in world war
ii in the battle of bataa
he is buried over there
on the where in a cemetery that they
basically buried all the troops that got
killed right there
he's buried there oh yeah but face style
they put a bunch of them in one spot
you know they would just dig graves they
and they had this protocol that they did
and they had government-issued raincoats
and they'd wrap the body up in the
raincoat and they'd bury it
and then they'd move on to their next
battle or whatever
well there's organizations out there
that are going through and trying to
find
all these soldiers and bring them back
to their homes wow
so sure enough i get a call from a
family
and they have been in touch with one of
these organizations and they have found
the remains of a guy from our town
at that at bataa
so what they did was they disinterred
his body and flew it to hawaii
and in hawaii they matched the dna
for him to one of his nieces
they matched that dna to confirm that it
was him
and then we started making the
arrangements
to get him back here so of course they
they booked the flight and they said
okay he's going to arrive
in nashville at such and such day and
such and such time
so you guys show up at the airport so we
show up at the airport with the family
and everything else
meet with the airport police at
nashville
and where do they come through baggage
come it's a large item like the golf bag
well they they they travel underneath
they travel underneath on the plane
but um when i was dealing with the
airline
um the airlines like
now what's gonna happen is we're gonna
go out there
and we're gonna bring his body here and
you can you know the family can receive
the body at the tar
you know hear baggage claim or actually
it's
kind of like air cargo oh yeah and um
and then the head of the airport police
he showed up and i and i started talking
to him
he said he said these are the cargo
people
he said i'm in charge he said you want
to go out to meet the plane
i said yeah i want to go out to meet the
plane he said well put everybody in your
vehicles and we'll go out and meet the
plane
and so they brought airport vans and
everything else and we went
we drove the hearst and everything out
to the tarmac
wow they brought they brought the you
know
because we had we had this was
pre-coveted so we had a full
detail of our of you know of army men
there
and they received the casket you know
right off the plane
carried him to the hearse and it was you
know it was a big deal you know
real emotional they had everybody in the
um
in the area like in the terminal come to
the glass
windows and they all watched it and they
were all holding flags and everything
else
as they took as they brought the body to
the hearse
and then after that then we brought him
all the way back
from out of the tarmac back to
hopkinsville and how big was he
well they had him in a full-sized casket
oh damn because
what they did was they crossed some
large they chronicled
everything that they had and you believe
it was really him or not i do
they had they had it down to they had
every one of its bones except for one
they had it all laid out they had all
the dna
they had everything about him they had
in this book that they gave to the
families and everything else
we um so we're coming back you know
we've got police escorts all the way
from nashville
all the way you know to to to the
kentucky state line
and that's when the tennessee people
broke off and then when we got to
christian county
um the sheriff's department was there
waiting on us
and i bet you they had about eight units
there and then when we got to the city
of hopkinsville
the city was there and the community
came out big for it
and the fire truck you know they took
the back big boom ladder and everything
else
and they had a huge american flag draped
that we drove under and everything else
and we took him out to uh [ __ ] we took
him out to the local
cemetery that um his
that his parents were buried at all his
brothers were buried there
and we buried him there i mean we even
had the pgr there
and um you know the pgr is another group
that we work with occasionally
and what they are is they're called
they're the patriot guard riders
and they're motorcycle guys and most of
them are veterans and everything else
but they really got a lot of notoriety
back when there was that group
from kansas that was going around
protesting military funerals
you could call the pgr and they'd show
up and they would show up
and so what they would do is they would
ride their motorcycles
you know with the funeral and when like
if you were coming up
to the cemetery or whatever and there
was the
protesters they'd stopped right there
and the protesters
in front of the protesters and rev those
motorcycles up you drive right on by and
you never could he'll
hear the protesters wow and so
that's really magical people come out to
support veterans you know yeah it means
a lot to people uh
especially to those families especially
getting to be back with your family i
think have you
you know just have your rest in place
back with their family there's something
beautiful about that
how uh if you're cleaning out somebody's
colon how
what if you don't get everything is
there a time lady you're like oh i gotta
run this
thing back again um sometimes you know
if you were
not to get everything you know you would
see some distending
distinction in the abdomen yeah and then
you would go back and you would do it
and you know you can watch it twice yeah
sam
now now what most people wash me twice
put a damn piece of spearmint in my ass
man you know i'm one
i just want to be fresh when i'm laying
there what some people don't think about
is once like when somebody drowns
they sink to the bottom but
as they start to decompose and those
gases
break up in that cavity that's what
causes them to float
and so sometimes especially
back home around the lake you know what
will happen
is somebody will drown and
you know so they're they don't might not
find them for a day or two
and then you know whenever
they start floating up you don't ever
know what time that's going to be
and sometimes what will happen is
they'll float up
and they'll get caught up in a barge
and that's either going either up river
or down river
wet hitchhiking and they won't notice it
until
daybreak and then they'll have to stop
the barge and then they've got a
lot of red tape and everything else and
you know they find this
person who's from kentucky up in
illinois
state lines yeah [ __ ] hitchhiking
exactly
now what about this you got that last
gas in you your body builds one
that last gas you have to let that out
normally
normally you can because when we use
that trocar
and you ever get that hit of gas you
ever get that gas
you can hit a gas pocket and it will you
know shrink up or whatever
but sometimes after you've used that
trocar
and you've there's a button that we use
that's kind of like a
screw in button that we put on the
person and
if they get distinction sometimes you
can just take that button
off and it'll release that pressure and
release that gas
and that's like a last part almost a
tinum i i guess you could call it that
and is it smell pretty bad a lot of
times it would yes
wow i want that
definitely i'm doing one you got to go
out with a with a you know
a last blast i think man
i can't tell if i'm more excited about
dying or not after talking to you
honestly frank
well you know as long as you've had a
good run on earth you know
there's time there's always a time to
check out don't get in a hurry
you only pass this way once that's it
huh that's right
do you feel like people will talk to you
about death a lot oh yeah
i always got questions do you uh
feel like um do you ever have somebody
wants to get dressed up in something
real wild like a nightgown or somebody
wants to be you know
dress their little cousin up like
superman or something well
you know therefore it kind of goes in
phases
like you'll have phases where you know
people will want to be buried in like
pajamas and stuff like that
and then sometimes you know you'll have
we have
in kentucky we have a lot of people that
like to be buried
in you know like uk jers
not necessarily jerseys but it might be
a uk fleece or
polo okay so state sports yeah right yes
rocking sports pride all the way to the
grave damn
yeah wow man what will you wear you
think
i'll definitely wear a suit probably a
blue one
you know probably blue looks good i like
blue suits it'll probably either be a
blue
or black you know pro but it won't be
plain it'll have
it'll have some type of stripe or weave
in it you know
okay bright tie you know probably you
know
maybe a red or you know a yellow
something like that something kind of
flashy you know it's always a tie
so go flash is kind of the way to go you
think a little bit so you know i
i when i dress i will dress a little
less conservative than some funeral
professionals but you know
because it's you know i'm in a suit
every day of my life you know just about
every day i wake up and i put a suit on
and so and so you know i like to
i don't like to just stick with you know
a solid brown a solid blue a solid black
and a solid gray
you know i've got on a gray pin stripe
today with the you know a bright pink
tie
you know and everything else in your
damn arms right now you look like i'm
right you know you're ready to help
somebody thank you
but you know that's you know that's me
you know
i've got a couple of suits that are that
some people say are a little bright
but you know that's that's my
personality i like to be
you know i'm here when you need me and
i'm here for the seriousness of it
but you know at the same time you know
it doesn't have to be all drab
have you ever had somebody die they want
to be dressed up like superman or
somebody dressed up like a damn you know
like a
wear like a you know uh dressed up like
he-man or
you know a miss butterworth or anything
like that somebody wants a particular
type of costume
um not so much as a costume like we've
had people who have worn like
a superman shirt or you know something
like that
and um but you know not a not a real
costume leo leotards and all that
no capes you know yeah what what will my
penis and stuff look like when i die
does it look the same or does it start
to look a little different
no it'll look pretty much the same nice
um and what about like um what happens
to fake breasts do y'all puncture them
and suck them out or leave now
you leave them oh they paid good money
for those hell yeah
boy you know what i'm saying
call me up i'll come over there and i'll
freaking put some makeup on those
on those mounds baby wow and do you have
to color the nipples at all with like a
powder or a dust
no because normally those are covered up
and what about the balls you have to
suck the stuff out of those
no wow
interesting man well man i think i'm
just dang
i guess i just know everything i know
now
do your eyes stay the same color they
were yes
that's cool
but of course they're closed so nobody
really sees them yeah
what bone was that guy missing the guy
that came back from
i'm not for sure i don't remember now
but they had
they had it they had a picture in the
book that they gave all the family
members
that had the entire skeleton laid out
wow and so
what if uh if somebody lost their legs
do you bury them in that full-size
casket or will you go a little shorter
on that
from that casket you'll go you'll still
use that full size
because it's like everything else if you
try to go
smaller you're going to be they don't
really make
smaller caskets on normal so it's going
to cost more
right whereas you know like if somebody
is really big
they have to get a bigger casket and
there's a company out there
or used to be a company out there called
goliath casting company wow
and their that was their niche market
was they made oversized caskets
and their two most popular models were
48 inches wide and 60 inches wide
so that's four and five feet wide on the
interior that's a damn queen bed
i mean it was they were big caskets but
when you needed them
you needed them can two people legally
be buried in one casket
technically i guess you could depending
on
most states but you know if but
most of the time most of the time they
don't go together
have you ever buried two and one i have
never buried two people in the same
casket
well let me rephrase that i have never
buried two full bodies in the same
casket
i have buried people like sometimes
one of them wants to be cremated and the
other one wants to be buried
and if the one that's cremated dies
first i have put their cremains in the
casket
with the other one when the other one
dies i've done that but i've not put
two two full bodies in the same casket
could you handle it can i handle it
as far as you'd have to have a wider
casket
but but i mean i guess i could do it if
i had to
hell yeah but you know we've had um i've
had double funerals but they've all been
in separate caskets
you know and is it cheaper to go two in
one casket
um no because i'll cut corners man
you know because because what happens is
it becomes more expensive because of
because when you're getting into that
bigger size
because a bigger size casket is
more expensive you know when you're
getting wider
and then also they're not they're not
as many out there as there are standard
size caskets and you can't just lay
somebody right on top of somebody else
that'd be tacky
yeah that'd be tacky what about um
um what's the smallest casket you've
ever done
uh it would be like an 18 inch
damn yeah like a damn baby snicker
almost
for like a stillborn baby oh
that's heartbreaking man
oh life is wild huh yeah one time we had
this situation
where um the um
a lady had had a baby who had died
and um she had
the baby had already been dead for 24
hours and was just sitting there
with the with the mother in the hospital
room because the mother was still in the
hospital
and i remember
i met with the baby's daddy about the
funeral arrangements
before they even release the body
because
the mother wasn't letting the baby go
wow
and so um so i told the
baby's daddy i said i said you just go
back to the hospital
and you tell him i'll be there at six
o'clock tonight
to pick up the body and when i get there
she'll need to give me the baby
and i told i got to the hospital signed
all the paperwork and everything else
and i told the nurses on the maternity
ward i said
i said i said i'm going to go in there
and i'm going to speak to the family
and then i'm going to take the baby on
back to the funeral home to go ahead and
work on preparing it for the funeral and
the the nurse laughed she said
she said i want you to know she said
she's had that baby
for over 24 hours she said and nobody's
taking it away from her
she said so um good luck with it good
luck with that but
you'll be here all night wow so you went
in there
so i went into the to the room there and
i spoke to all the family that was there
and she gave me the
she gave me the baby and when i walked
out of the room with the baby
she started screaming and you know
because she was so overwhelmed with
grief
and i could still hear her screaming
when i got on the elevator
oh and because it's so it's so hard to
lose
you know to lose a child it's so
unnatural that you don't know how you
would react
nobody knows how they're going to react
until they're in that situation
you know it's easy to look look
look at it and say oh i would never
react that way
but you don't know how you're going to
react oh yeah i mean
i mean that's that's somebody's child or
that's somebody's spouse
and you know when they get overcome with
grief
you just got to be there for them and
you know if they need to
if they need to cry and scream you just
got to kind of help them cry and scream
but if you know whatever they need to be
you know
it's you've just got to be there for
them you know death brings out the worst
in people but it also brings out the
best in people
so you never know you never know how
somebody's going to react
you just got to be there for them and
what do you carry a baby like that in
that that's that that's that size man
that's just that's heartbreaking
um we wrap them in a baby blanket
and we and we carry them just like they
were if that
you would if they were a live child and
do you sit them up in the front seat or
do you put them in the back or what do
you do
um most of the time what we would do
is we would in a situation like that
we would have we would take
a car and two people and so one person
would hold the baby in the car
and the other one would drive wow
you know they make they make what is
called
it's it's like a box that you could put
the baby in
for um you know to transport it but
i'm not putting a baby in a black box
that looks like a tackle box to you know
or something like that i don't
i don't think that's fitting and
appropriate so we don't use those type
of things
wow we just use the baby blanket because
babies should be in a baby blanket
whether they're alive or dead and they
shouldn't be
you know they shouldn't be thrown in a
box you wouldn't carry a
you wouldn't carry you know a live one
like that i'm not gonna carry a dead one
like that
amen oh
working at the finish line man you're
working at the finish line
that's right sometimes that finish
line's
real short to the starting line and
sometimes it's real far away
but you know you got to be there for all
of it
wow
yeah it's fascinating man uh i don't i
think i i don't know if there's anything
else that i can
take out of you today man except just to
say thank you very much and
and what's the name yells outfit over
there it's hugger beard and giles
funeral home in hopkinsville kentucky
wow well thank you so much man for
coming in and just filling us in on
everything that's in that world you know
frank giles thank you so much today man
oh last question when the undertaker
remember the wrestler when he really
popped off remember yep did that put a
lot of pressure on you guys as uh
as undertakers and stuff like that to
really take it to another level
no but you know a lot of times when when
he was really big in wrestling
you know it would be you know i would
get a lot of comments you know if they'd
be like
hey undertaker let me be your manager
let me be your manager you know
let me be your pallbearer you know yeah
and so
but yeah those were some those are some
interesting times
but did it put pressure on you to like
you know did it make you feel like oh i
got to
you know be more athletic or i got to
show up and yell or you know like
anything that really
did it make it did it put any pressure
on the industry no no we weren't out
there practicing the tombstone power
drive or anything like that you know
but uh i did it didn't make me go hit
the gym or anything like that
yeah yeah i just always wondered that
man
frank giles thank you so much for being
here today man really really appreciate
it and thanks for just kind of welcoming
us into your world
and what it's like it seems like uh
you're just kind of walking along a
really unique part of of
existence you know you're just kind of
you're kind of you're not really guiding
people but you are kind of you're just
right there with them
that's right you know and the thing
about it
is is it's kind of like if you fall in a
hole
and your neighbor jumps in that hole
with you and you'd say
well why did you jump in the hole with
me and you know it's well i've been here
before and i've gotten
i've gotten out and so i'm i'm here you
know i've been
i've been through it with before i'll
guide you right all through
yeah amen man well thanks for guiding us
through this chat today frank giles we
appreciate it
you're quite welcome honored to be here
now i'm just floating on the breeze and
i feel
i'm falling like these leaves i must be
cornerstone
but when i reach that ground i'll share
this piece of mind i found i can
feel it in my bones
but it's gonna take a little time
for me to set that parking brake and let
myself
on my heart shine that light on
me
[Music]
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy load of
my
hands
[Music]
built